(slow clapping)
- Good morning, Believe Nation!
Today's message is:
- Find happiness and
over to you, Lilly Singh.
(rooster crowing)
(slow hip hop music)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ When Entspresso keep me going.
- I was in my last year of university,
just going through a really tough time.
I wasn't really doing anything for myself
and then I discovered YouTube.
And I remember the first
time I saw a video,
I was like, "What is this thing?
This magical thing on the Internet?"
And so, I uploaded a video spontaneously.
I kept doing it simply
because it made me happy.
It made a sad person happy.
I've learned happiness
is the hardest thing
you will ever fight for in your life.
It's the only thing worth
fighting for in your life.
Everyone's been sad,
everyone's been through things,
but I think it's really what
you do with those feelings
and you do with those dark times
and the ability to change
them into something beautiful.
- So what do you think?
- This girl, Lilly Singh, I love the video
because she, her word is happiness
and happiness is what the world needs
like to be more fun and creative
just like the little kids around you.
I mean, if you have
family with little kids
or kids of your own.
So, they're always joyful and
they're always playful
and that's the happiness we need to find
within us to be more happy with ourself,
embrace everything we've got
and believe in ourself more
than anyone in the world.
Simply like that.
Because if you don't believe in yourself,
no one else will so you
have to believe enough
to make others believe in you.
So my advice to whoever is watching,
write three things for
which you are grateful for.
Just for writing it, it will make you
really come alive
and be happier
and be with gratitude
with what you already have
or what you are trying
to achieve in your life.
- So I agree.
I love gratitude, I have a daily practice
that I've put in for the past couple years
of three things I'm
grateful for every morning.
I brought it to my team.
I brought it to YouTube as well.
I think it's really important that
a lot of times, the
things that make you happy
may not make sense yet.
Like, you don't understand how do I turn
this thing that makes me so happy into
a business or a career
because it may not be
totally laid out, you know.
So for me, I love helping entrepreneurs.
And the first thing I did was
having a seminar to help entrepreneurs
and only three people
showed up to my free seminar
and I thought if only three
people show up to a free thing,
how am I ever going to make
a business out of this?
How is that ever going to happen?
Logically, it doesn't make sense but
I just love doing it so much.
It filled me with so much joy,
helping entrepreneurs,
having new entrepreneurs on the channel,
I love doing it.
And so I have to find a way to keep going.
And I eventually figured it out.
I eventually built a website,
eventually built a YouTube channel.
You know, the execution of
it, I figured out with time.
And I think, if you have
something that brings you
joy, that brings you happiness,
you owe it to yourself to
continue down that path
to try to figure out how
to turn it into something
that can be amazing for you,
even if it doesn't make
total sense yet right now
because that's way better than you
thinking, "Okay, well I can never
make that a success so I'm going to just
get this job that I hate doing and
stay there for the rest of my life
and never be happy."
I think too many people do that.
I think too many people wake up
and they drive to a job that they hate
every day and they never
get to express themselves
or be creative or have
that joy or freedom.
And so, when you find that thing,
that makes you happy,
find a way to keep that as a
part of your life every day.
Build some momentum
towards it every single day
and if you do that, some
amazing things will happen.
So the question of the day today is:
- When you think about happiness,
what three things come to your mind?
- Leave it in the comments below.
We're going to join in the discussion.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed and
have an amazing day.
We believe in you
and hope you continue to
believe in yourself and...
- Whatever you one word is!
- I will see you again tomorrow morning
for another...
- Shot!
Of Entspresso.
- What did you do?
You did three like this?
- Yeah.
- Like this, wow.
I do this.
Canada!
Venezuela!
Okay, what three or three things?
(slow hip-hop music)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'